- what hey what's up everyone welcome to
simulation we have a very special
episode today it's our first time
talking about quantum computing on the
show I am super excited to have dr.
Williams and joining us thanks thank you
for coming on so well
yeah greatly appreciate it great to be
here and your backgrounds awesome
physics at Yale and then at Oxford for
computer science for PhD and now I want
to Righetti quantum computing three and
a half years now yeah it goes by quickly
there's a lot to do how did you even
like pick you know physics and computer
science and quantum computing how did
you you know figure out that that's what
you cared about so I'm I got into it
pretty early which is like not that
common for people to find something
there that into and stick with I
definitely have fought with it of
different parts of my career but I read
about it I think in like there was a
scientific American article back when I
was 14 or 15 and it was about how you
know you could prove that a certain kind
of computer could be better than this
than any computer that we could build
and that's if you made a quantum
computer we can talk a lot more about
what that means but really what
attracted me to it was that there's this
synthesis of two things in quantum
computing that's that's very rare and
that's the chance to work on something
that's very fundamental and is about you
know the fundamental things in physics
and how does that relate to information
and I really hope we talk about this a
lot more but then also build technology
that could help people and it's pretty
rare to work on us in business of those
two things and so I kind of like
stumbled upon that when I was a teenager
and then had been kind of like trying to
find my way into the field ever since
and I met some great mentors and ended
up in it and have been able to work in
it for pretty much my whole adult life
now hooked in when you were young that's
the key yeah yeah it's wanting to be at
that fundamental layer of physics and
understanding reality and then then
making that applicable to something that
we do everyday in so many ways
computation yeah and processing okay so
I mean there's so much to talk about
your quantum computing scientist so that
you know there's so much to do with this
there's you know the art there's the
design and the architecture of
the actual super computing processors
there's the there is everything that
you're doing with regards to the
software side of things on the cloud as
well there's so much that goes into this
the cryogenic side of it I mean where do
you we've been finding out how much
there is like overtime right you know
you set out and we were a very small
team and then we've just kind of learned
about how much is actually gonna need to
go into building these systems for the
first time yeah and and so you were very
early like three four third or fourth
and they're definitely in the first
group in the first group in the company
you're up to like 120 people now like 40
phd's just going hard at trying to
figure this out
and so you know I think something that's
really important too you know I'm really
grateful that you brought this so we can
call this a super computing
superconducting processor
superconducting processor it's not
superconducting right now if it was you
would be be very cold so okay so so now
a superconducting processor we are we
are not using electricity or are we
using electricity you are you're using
electromagnetic waves in the way that we
build it there's a bunch of it's
actually a whole field of
superconducting electronics yes
but the kind we use is to make quantum
computers to amplify the quantum effects
of things that are happening yeah and so
we are using electromagnetic fields and
signals yes okay so so the classical
style and will be will be short on this
and then we'll spend a lot of our time
talking more about how this helps us
move forward as humanity but the but the
very general idea rather than having a
transistor for a 0 or a 1 or and on or
an off there is that and that can only
be in a binary on or off state this
enables a super positioning of the is it
it's a photon yes so in our case it's
it's a microwave photons microwave for
whether or not you have or don't have a
microwave photon it's sort of a 0 & 1
and because it's a quantum mechanical
state you can get these mixtures that
are called super positions and then if
you have multiple
of them you can cause correlations
between them called entanglement and
these things plus some other details can
be used for doing new kinds of
computation okay so the microwave photon
can be in a state and this is an eight
qubit when you're holding is one that we
team made last year last year so this is
eight qubits so there's eight microwave
photons that can either be in a state of
zero or one at the same time yeah
there's usually we always end up having
more photons kind of around but the
computational bits are these eight
microwave resonators and it's the
occupation of photons in those
resonators that we actually use for the
coffee cake if we could get rid of all
the other photons that would sometimes
be really useful okay and then the and
then this enables a significant increase
in processing yeah yes well not this
size but if we scale it up and continue
to improve the performance then that's
the trajectory we want to be yes so like
128 qubits is what your roadmap for and
so we talked about that recently yeah so
one of the like big so this is a this is
a chip which is seems kind of similar at
first glance to other kinds of chip so
you have for computing but it's not
exact it actually is very very different
the way it behaves the fundamental thing
the things that you mentioned
superposition entanglement there's other
kinds of things you get in quantum
computing previously people thought they
could only access these features for
computation by working with systems that
were already very quantum mechanical
there's maybe one way to think about it
yeah you know they started to try and
work with ions or electron States or
like very small particles and to try and
make them behave like computers and then
over the last 15 years there's been this
other approach which is that you can
actually build chips like the one that
you're holding I mean this approach
called superconducting qubits that are
relatively big but still behave like
these quantum mechanical particles and
so the last 15 years has seen a bunch of
really fantastic academic work places
like Gaylord UC Santa Barbara and now
many many other other groups to kind of
bring this field of superconducting
qubits to the floor so that we can use
these chips to make the world's first
real quantum computers
and I said at forgetty and IBM and
Google are actually all using this kind
of chip based approach so that that's
one of the big shifts that's been really
important in the field in the last let's
say five years or so yeah okay and we
have some let's pull up some of the
images that we have to show this in a
little bit more of its larger scale with
detail as well actually people if you
pull up the totem and then maybe we
let's do it let's you can show you a
little bit about okay what kind of goes
into a full quantum computing let's do
that so this is a fun fun little graphic
we could actually you know as someone
who's a scientist so mike in an academic
background it's been really fun being in
a company and working with people who
are like professional communicators and
visual communicators this is really good
yeah and it's a fun little thing so what
we've got here is the like stack of
computing we're having it on our team
you know this guy David Bryan has really
taken on this challenge of trying to
help describe this abstracting of
quantum computing in little graphics and
different ways so one of things we're
working on yeah but so at the bottom
we've got a chip and this is kind of a
graphic for that and that's like what
you're holding here this goes yeah okay
and so the our fabrication team in in
Fremont actually makes these we have we
built the world's first superconducting
quantum processor fabrication plant in
the world with venture money so it
wasn't easy but just like a really great
great team down there builds these chips
and then they get hooked up into
refrigerators I mean you just call the
refrigerators they're fancy I mean they
go all the way down to ten milli Calvin
and how much colder is that then you
know zero Celsius well a lot so hey
that's ten thousandth of a degree above
absolute zero so it's just above
absolute zero yes absolute zero is where
all the molecules are and all the atoms
aren't moving out okay that means
there's no kinetic energy they're frozen
so there's just a little bit of motion
and that any that kind of noise and that
kind of motion causes errors in quantum
computation it's one of the reasons we
don't see quantum effects at scale
normally so quantum mechanics applies to
everything we've known about this for
you know hundred years ago now but if
things are hot and the inter
with lots of things yeah then the
quantum-mechanical features all sort of
many can sort of think of it as
averaging out to being classical to
being Newtonian physics to being the
stuff you learn about in high school so
you lose the power so we have to keep
these things cold
in order to make sure that none of this
it's really all about information
leaking and your interactions so if you
keep things isolated and control then
you get these quantum mechanical
benefits and so that's kind of this
layer like where we build these
cryogenic systems and we'll show a
picture later that it cools them down
and controls them and we have a team
that's building control systems for
these and calibrates them and all this
stuff and then it actually at the end of
the day it could builds up into a cloud
platform yep so we've had these these
are still prototype processors so
they're not faster than regular
computers yet or the fashion
supercomputers yet but very early on we
wanted to make them accessible so that
folks could start to practice and learn
a little bit about quantum computing
it's very different programming model
and try to help figure out how to best
use these processors as soon as they can
and so we talked about Righetti we
talked about ourselves
sometimes as a full-stack quantum
computing platform give us an idea of
the size of the totem in is the same
about the size of my forearm oh the size
of the yeah of the yeah of the
everything here oh no so yes so we have
a picture of the one of the dilution
refrigerators if you go to the tower
these things are kind of about about
this much in in diameter and they're
maybe like a half tall it's about this
big yeah it's kind of like this chair
and the chip will go into the bottom
here yeah and then we'll cool the whole
thing down and you'll control it so in
this case the here is your cryogenic
system right here well it's even more
than this it's this so this is kind of a
gut so the refrigerator this is called
evolution refrigerators but it's the
fridge yeah and then there's all this
other supporting system around it that
actually does the cooling so this isn't
even the whole thing and if you come to
Berkeley we've got a kind of array of
these and kind of the first one kind of
called like a proto quantum data center
which is not like a series of things
that I thought I would be like in
graduate school this is the thing like
it's it's gone so much
quickly in some ways like when I was in
grad school programming a quantum
computer was something you did by like
writing mathematical symbols down or
writing papers like I never like in my I
did a PhD in quantum algorithms and I
never really like I coded a method that
did some proofs like it and I never
actually had a programming language to
work with and today you know we've got
students grad students who can sign up
with you get an API key and program
quantum computers like it's a real thing
yeah so it's happening it's happening
pretty fast I know that sometimes like a
little bit a little bit jealous but one
of the most rewarding things about both
that things becoming more accessible and
then also that sort of talked a little
about how all the things we do at
Righetti for me has been all those
people that you get to be around yeah
like you like I get to learn from
experts in the world and you know the
guys we've hired in from from Intel or
or they're like fantastic chip
manufacturing companies to work on
superconducting quantum processes for
the first time right that attracts
people who want to do really new things
yeah and it's in all fields right so
I've been lucky enough to work on
different parts I've like worked on
calleb different byte software to
calibrate the chips or the program that
but kind of just enough to know like
just do some of the prototyping to know
that like when we need to bring in the
professionals at each one of those
layers yeah so that's kind of what we're
what we're starting to do at each of the
layers in the stack and that's kind of
its kind of how we how we yeah damn just
even thinking about it
compartments a slightly compartmentalize
like that and how you need absolute
cutting-edge professionals in the fields
to be able to put this together okay you
started talking about the programming
language I think this is very
interesting what does quantum computing
programming teach us about normal ways
of programming yeah yeah there this is a
hot-button topic for me so I I can talk
a lot about this I think the first thing
to realize is that because you're
changing computation at such a
fundamental level it's not just about
bits anymore and it's not about boolean
logic anymore actually it's not it's not
about and
and or and XOR and these like
fundamental things you learn in
computing it's a different model so when
you think about programming typically
you think about these some of these big
paradigms you get invented right
distributed programming functional
programming I'll be joining and
programming quantum programming is kind
of like a whole other branch yeah so
it's not just a different language it's
really a different branch of computing
which is if you were kind of a computer
scientist like me and you're fascinated
by what it means to do computing and and
that sort of thing then this this is
really cool to to work with and teach us
about how it's different like that it's
a whole new branch yeah and it and so at
the bottom so one of the major flavors
or the things you have to deal with to
get your head around quantum programming
is that there's linear algebra machines
so they work with big matrices and big
vectors and in some ways we can write on
the coattails of how many people have
been learning linear algebra in
programming to do machine learning
because they've sort of to do ml today
you you also need to work with they're
kind of these same kind of mathematical
to you know and so on a similarity so
there's there's a lot of mathematical
similarities there I'm computing an ml
lots of similarities good the matrix you
use it exactly like these if you're
working with big vector spaces
now we're hopeful that that will mean
that we can use quantum computers to do
machine learning and there's some super
cool papers that have come out recently
about this topic but it's pretty gentle
I guess like we're starting to figure
out how these things might impractical I
want to get back to the difference in
the programming style so I mean just
some some basic practical things you
know that doesn't just because the
programming models are very different
doesn't mean that it's not something
that you can pick up quickly right so
one of the first things we did at
Righetti is I worked with a couple
colleagues on defining an instruction
set architecture for quantum programming
called quilt yeah which is it's an
opinionated quantum instruction language
so it's kind of like an assembly level
definition for how a quantum computer
should work we weren't ready to think of
a programming
I don't even know if we are yet now that
the opinion it has is that these quantum
chips will work in concert with
classical processors in a particular way
and so the instruction set targets these
- it's called a shared memory model
mm-hmm and so it gets the quantum
processor working with regular
processors in a way that takes advantage
of both and we can talk more about that
but I mean one of the other cool things
about working on that is another example
of something I mentioned you earlier the
first author on the kind of quills back
in paper and one of the like my main
collaborators on it is I call a Robert
Smith who hadn't done any quantum
mechanics really as he done a little bit
recreationally until he joined Righetti
and he just had to use it he had a great
background in in mathematical physics
and mathematical programming and he
brought this this different view you
know if you talk to someone who was a
quantum information person like me they
don't think about instruction sets you
know they think about all these like
physics things about quantum information
and wave functions and stuff and and he
helped bring that lens in and and so I
had some ideas about okay hybrid and
this and and he had this mathematical
side and so we were able to make this
instruction set and we've seen that kind
of stuff happen over and over again in
different areas as we bring in experts
to work on it does yeah it it uses with
the importance of multidisciplinary
thinking yeah and okay so now tell us
about quill because this is very
interesting you want to be able to
connect that that shared memory between
a quantum computer and a normal
processing computer that we have in our
houses already so that way you can
offset some of the processing the major
processing for all these different uses
that we're going to go over and a little
bit yeah so the big the big shift on the
hardware side was that we could make
chips that behaved like quantum systems
so that meant we could scale up the
hardware and that's a big thing happen
in the last five years on the software
side has also been a big shift and that
shift is to go away from thinking about
quantum computers as something that's
going to be a standalone machine and
towards these more integrated systems
where quant we just work with regular
computers
the reason for this shift is that before
we have big and perfect quantum
computers we're gonna have small and
noisy ones like this yeah so ones that
still have some errors you know their
qubits are maybe a little unreliable
they perform a little differently than
how you calibrated them and stuff like
this
so to deal with that you need to
compensate by adding in classical
resources
well one of the ways to do this is to
add in classical resources and to do
things like instead of just running one
quantum program you run a parameterised
quantum program that you optimize with
the classical processor in some kind of
iterative loop so you kind of one way to
maybe think about that is that it's like
your machine learning what the quantum
program should be or you you kind of
take a long quantum computation and you
find a way to break it into small
quantum computations that you can
assemble an answer from and these
algorithms are sometimes called hybrid
algorithms and and to support them you
need to have an integrated quantum
classical system and that that's pretty
that's what we've been building like
that's that's kind of been the focus at
at Righetti since the beginning it's
okay we're gonna have these processors
like in these fridges and how do we make
a platform on top of them that people
can actually use and over the last I
guess we had our first processors come
up in kind of second half of last year
and since then we've seen people from I
guess 30 or 40 countries running on the
platform they've run more than nine like
160 million quantum programs and so like
you think maybe okay yeah this is only
something that a few people are gonna
think about but the potential is so huge
that folks want to practice and the way
to learn programming is to iterate like
I was I learned programming by hacking
most people do yeah and so now we have a
quantum pretty deep knock on and that
it's really helpful to learn how to do
stuff with it and then they when they
get signed up they get signed up to use
your quartz and computational abilities
through the internet they're not getting
a physical quantum computer at the right
doorstep yeah okay which is good because
the physical quantum computers are still
pretty expensive yeah I mean they're
also kind of complicated to operate so
in those in Berkeley just via yes just
via the web I'm I'm leasing time on your
quantum computers that's the set up yeah
yeah and it's another example something
that's moved fast I think you know one
of the first general conversations I had
with with Chad Righetti who's the
founder of regatta computing and our CEO
I think one of the first things we
really bonded on is he said I I want to
build a quantum computer and put it
online for free yeah this was in late
2014 you were talking about this and it
took a little bit but we did that for
you and and it wasn't even actually just
us IBM also did it yeah and I think
we've we've kind of realized that a way
to help this field grow is to be kind of
transparent about how how things are
developing yeah and to try and make it
accessible for folks to to use that's
why I'm very excited that that's that's
one way the industry has has gone and
they're like the code is open source and
it's in Python and like all the good
stuff is is pretty exciting so open
source code in Python there is leasing
time on the quartz computer is this open
transparent sort of community trying to
run these more complicated processing
intensive calculations on your time on
your lease on your quantum computer so
let's talk about what this means for the
future of of that now you know there are
so many people that are running these
really intense simulations or figuring
out how to optimize IT security in
general yeah take us down this path yeah
so we're not we're not running like big
production workloads yet we want to get
there but there's there's these we're
kind of in that prototype
proof-of-concept phase for how to use
these early quantum processors and here
there's this with a three major actually
it's kind of like if we look at what our
users are doing know what the community
is doing this is just kind of four major
buckets one of them is in it I'm gonna
start with is simulation problems so
they're trying to simulate how a
physical system behaves using another
physical system our chip
and a lot of things in quantum mechanics
are hard to compute so sometimes
computing ground state energies or
chemical properties or binding energies
and stuff like this are difficult to do
on a regular supercomputer and one of
the reasons they're difficult is that
quantum mechanics has all these
correlations and subtle details that
require very large vector spaces to
model and that's exactly what these
things have to so it's kind of the thing
that makes these simulation problems
difficult is what gives quantum
computers their power and so some of the
first uses for quantum computing and so
element we see a lot of people running
our small simulations things like how is
how is some catalysts gonna behave and
you know and you you might you might
think that this is something that only a
few folks will care about that like a
few scientists will care about but
actually a lot of it like catalysis is a
big part of some huge industrial scale
processes one of the ones that is is
good to talk about is nitrogen fixation
which sounds obscure but it's used to
make it's part of the cost for making
fertilizer I was taught by otech
probably well we'll we have to see but
like we talked to folks and and they so
when to make fertilizer you take
nitrogen out of the atmosphere and turn
it into ammonia using a process called
the haber-bosch process which was
invented in the early 1900s
kind of by brute force looking through a
bunch of catalysts to do this reaction
turns out uranium works as a catalyst
but they found another one which is not
your aim which is also good which is
iron based one and the thing about it is
it operates at 400 degrees calcia Sande
Celsius and 200 atmospheres of pressure
so to get the yeah the catalytic
reaction happen you have to throw a
bunch energy at this system and we make
so much fertilizer to feed a growing
planet that one to two percent of the
world's energy output every year goes to
this reaction damn so if you right now I
didn't I didn't actually know about this
as a as a business computer scientist so
I started talking to folks one two
percent of total global energy budget
yeah ghost of making fertilizer for
growing food
well I don't know you see brother sir
maybe I wouldn't use it as a fragrance
yeah
okay you can't you use fertilizer for
making bombs it's true and one other
thing we could talk about it's like some
of the and then we struggle with this
right like if you're building a big
technology like quantum computing it's
like well how is this gonna be used or
misused yeah and that fixer oh that's
really important I mean it comes out of
physics and physics lost its naivety
around the Manhattan Project yeah around
stuff like this and yeah
yeah that's been talking about its own
sake yeah ethics who's gonna go bucs and
yeah keep going guys yeah who's gonna
teach humans you're all doing the work
fingers crossed
who's go we gotta have more than hope we
have to have a plan yeah you know okay
so continue on the fertilizer and then
we'll sew it well just to kind of sum
that up we know that there are better
ways of doing this reaction because
there's bacteria that do it at ambient
temperature and pressure much more
efficiently we just don't how they work
and one of the hopes is that we can use
a quantum computer to simulate the
system and design a better catalyst and
if you make a 10% better catalyst than
you'd like decreased our energy bill for
the planet very well yeah and there's
other kinds of things like this would be
useful like wire plants so much better
at photosynthesis than anything we've
built yeah yeah there may be some
quantum effects in the electron
transport chain this is all there's a
lot of stuff to to kind of look at and
study on that simulation side yes
so efficiencies are huge trying to
figure those out across how nature has
been so efficient and try and replicate
that in biomimic yeah and I think I even
farther like like it's one thing to so
nature guides us a little bit but we we
should also be able to be better than
nature
oh yeah if we get this thing we're not
waiting for genetic says you do better
than nature yeah yeah so my favorite
example of that is they're like so the
secondary or major area that people are
doing stuff in is
is in machine learning again very like
early stage their training like little
classifiers to classify three and five
and m-miss not even the whole m-miss
dataset yet but it's early and so like
if I like preempt a question that I get
a lot is like so do you think our brains
are quantum mechanical and you think
that you know quantum computers are
going to help us make AGI because we can
we can do biomimicry
what's your answer that I don't think so
my answer is I well clarify which bit I
don't I think it's very unlikely that
our brains are quantum mechanical
they're wet and hot so they did they
have all this like averaging out
behaviors that happen there's been a
couple interesting papers where folks
who look at okay if we were to try and
find something neurons not firing until
it actually fires this and there's no
superposition
yes far as we can tell I mean it would
be weird for it to have a superposition
to because it said it's very hot like
it's a very it's at room temperature
right so for us to take something like
this and it's big like a neuron and to
make it behave so it has superposition
it has to be a 10 milli Calvin yeah
we're not yeah yeah okay there's some
there's some there's still some cool
papers we will try and figure out like
what could maybe be a quantum mechanical
effect in the brain
there was a paper there were a few
people who thought that maybe
so I guess pigeons have some
navigational ability to detect the
Earth's magnetic field yeah it's a
molecule in their eye and that's
probably like a quantum effect so so
maybe evolution it would be weird if no
evolution took advantage of quantum
mechanics yeah so how can we mimic that
make it even better and write it
ourselves so you know it's not whether
it's not is our brain quantum mechanical
it's what if we built a brain that was
it was yeah and that's and that's I
think a much more interesting question
building a brain that is called a
mechanical is that is very easy I asked
it seems so what was it what's the
answer the second question which part
about AGI and quantum mechanics
we don't know yet I think I think that
it that's pretty much this stage of the
question I think what what if we built a
brainless yeah and like there's not
really a huge body of evidence to reply
back yes we're looking at but that seems
to be it if I if you have a hundred
twenty eight or 256 qubits we're
starting to approach a level of
processing that is just amazing well I
think it's amazing but I don't I
wouldn't I wouldn't say like out of the
box it's gonna be age would be it's
gonna be out of the box yeah open it is
this another toolkit to put into the
tool box right now we're seeing we're
seeing professionalized processors for
machine learning just keeping to keep e
use or other kinds of things we're just
talking about sheer amount of data that
can be input and then processed and
that's what's really just going to
enable you run like we should also talk
about all these different uses that you
know you're talking about the the kind
of the main use is that it's being used
for right now for you guys right but the
the future of what this is going to be
used for is incredibly important it's
not gonna be GI out at the box but
there's being able to run these bigger
simulations being able to quantum
communication and quantum encryption
these things are these are major parts
of our future yeah if you think on a
long time frame I think it'd be
surprising to see them not be it's I
mean just to maybe I should finish the
other 40 so ml optimization and then the
LAT the fourth big category and this
kind of leads into what I want to say
about how it'll be weird for it not to
be yeah yeah his games games yeah right
and I simulations and games are very
well yeah it's like but it's also like
it we get these weird mechanics like you
like you get everyone wants to play with
a new game mechanic to make their game
stand out a little bit and if you get
the quantum mechanical effects in there
then you can like make super positions
on a battleship game that there's a guy
named James Wooten who used to be at the
University of Basel and he's now you
know working at IBM who built kind of
this like a series of games yeah they're
really fine swear it was on f4 dude no
it was actually it was and it was
we should have better like you say James
Wooten yeah he owes me money
I want him gambling man like you know so
you can make one of the things you can
make with quantum systems are random
number generators that as far as we can
tell are truly random right so they're
most of the way random numbers are
generated in computers are to use these
things called pseudo random number
generated a laburnum which are not
actually random it's a deterministic
sequence but the statistics of the
numbers you get when we test them look
random yeah but in quantum mechanics you
get stuff that's actually random huh
like does a photon go left or right as
far as we can tell you know if it's
actually you know quantum mechanics is
right then this is truly random and so
people can build these random number
generators that are kind of quantum
mechanically we believe them to be
better random number generator that is
huge for simulations and games and well
it's huge yet but like for people who
are like casinos who really need to
generate random numbers there's only
random I don't want anyone taking
advantage of bias I think they actually
look at this kind of stuff ya know also
encryption like
two-factor authentication all this other
kind of stuff really no random number
generators but I don't think it's in
it's like very it's like nice but the
thing is the thing that I wanted to like
bring up about that is like so we have
things like games quantum computers
scientific simulations other kinds of
technologies that are quantum and aren't
just computers yeah if you zoom out a
little bit we're not just talking about
quantum computers we're talking about
quantum technology technology right and
so this is like if we look at the last
you know 200 years every time we learn
more about how physics works and how
nature works we get not just one
technology but a whole bunch of whole
boys right so we figured out
thermodynamics and mechanics and we were
able to have the Industrial Revolution
yeah right with steam engines just looms
lots of things then we get Maxwell's
equations and electrodynamics
electromagnetics yeah and we can build
the whole electronics revolution yes yes
and we've learned a bit about quantum
mechanics and it's played a part
in how transistors work so transistors
wouldn't work of quantum mechanics
wasn't true but we haven't actually
embraced quantum technology in a way
that takes advantage of all the really
kinda yeah unintuitive and weird and
powerful stuff that goes on in it and I
think that's the long-term bet like that
that's what we're gonna start to see
over the next 50 or a hundred years is
you're not gonna just have electrical
engineering departments mechanical
engineering departments you're gonna
have quantum particles yeah yeah where
there's these different kinds of
technologies that take advantage of the
stuff that happens in quantum mechanics
and and really really exploit it I like
how you gave us the vision of how the
Industrial Revolution blossomed all
these technologies than the electronics
revolution we're just at the very
nascent stage of the quantum technology
revolution and it's about to be in every
single facet of our lives I mean so many
different areas not in two years but
like let's take this any 20 years well
your show you get to we get to make 50
year we just talk about a long time yeah
yeah that's good yeah okay let's let's
unpack some of those that we mentioned
earlier in as much detail as you'd think
is important let's talk about encryption
quantum encryption and quantum
communication and what that means yeah
so there's there's sort of three if you
look at a taxonomy of quantum technology
today yeah there are three pillars
quantum computing which we talked about
you know using computer technology to
solve problems we can't solve today
there's communications which is making
networks which they're proof of security
is only reliant on the fact that quantum
mechanics is accurate
yeah which which is great like if you
look at RSA today remote most encryption
schemes today they rely on some
conjecture something that's not that's
more like often it's believing that
factoring is hard so believing that if I
give you a number it's hard to find its
prime factors and we think that's hard
you know people there's a lot of money
on the line for people to try and do
that yeah
but we've never proven that it's hard
right and there's some reasons to think
that it actually may or may not it might
actually not be hard in general to do
someone put them computing
well even given a regular computer so
we've not proven that classical
computers can't factor numbers easily we
just don't know how so there is some
chance that even without a quantum
computer somebody figures out how to do
it but also what we know is that if you
had a quantum computer then factoring is
easy so if you on the communication side
you know you sort of switch to this way
of sending information where instead of
believing that factoring is hard you
just have to believe that quantum
mechanics is accurate yeah but you know
big Asterix here is that you know that's
nobody ever breaks an encryption scheme
by breaking the like fundamental proof
like they break it by like calling you
and telling you they're your bank and
making you give them social engineering
and side-channel attacks yeah like it's
it's but it's still it's a like it's a
very quantum communications quantum so
you can your secret sharing these things
pick them and you can build a lot of
these really interesting schemes with
quantum networks that I think will also
to play a role so the third pillar
though is sensing sensing quantum
sensing so you can build sensors that
are more accurate than any non quantum
machine and like any server a really
important for autonomous vehicles and
like that the the it's where you really
need accuracy over time so one of the
biggest areas that people in that field
like to talk about is clocks so atomic
clocks are one of the first maybe
quantum technologies like pure quantum
technologies Dave Wineland run that won
the Nobel for his working and the thing
that I think a lot of people don't
realize is how dependent we are on GPS
for telling where we are yeah and if the
GPS satellites went down then you could
you could lose your sense of location
because you would lose your sense of
timing and so folks that really need to
have accurate GPS if GPS networks go
down
governments or trading platforms may
need have much more accurate timing
that's decentralized right so they have
to have very accurate clocks so quantum
sensors are and there's other kinds of
ways of doing things with sensors but
those are kind of the three big pillars
so it's not just computing yeah if you
have a quantum computer though it can
help us design those other ones yeah and
so encryption goes hand-in-hand with the
communication yeah so encryption goes
handy with communication but decryption
goes with the computer so if you've had
I think the thing that the thing that
got people first interested in applying
quantum computers was that Peter shor
showed in 94 that you could easily
factor numbers so if you had a big
imperfect quantum computer you could
break into most crypto systems today
thank you Ron
danger when you break all encryption
yeah so a lot of when we started out was
was we you talk to me when they'd be
like oh you're building machine to break
encryption and that's just not it's not
accurate we're gonna have probably 20
years of doing stuff in machine learning
optimization and simulation before we
even try and run anything at that scale
and by then people will have shifted
over so NIST for example has had put out
a call asking for post quantum
cryptography relatively recently so
they're gonna they're gonna switch in
time it's kind of missed the national in
super standards and technology in the
u.s. of nationalists to first science
and technology standards standards and
technology you didn't know what that
meant
missed everybody knows what everyone
knows well now I get to like it yes this
throws me money okay so let's let's talk
about this so I think as we as we kind
of wrap up I think something that we
haven't talked about too much yet that
we definitely wanted to talk about was
what this means for understanding
reality in general because we did you
gave us the good break down of
Industrial Revolution electronics
revolution now quantum technology
revolution
and you know what we're digging into
regarding quantum mechanics is just
giving us a tremendous amount of insight
into reality so like what does this mean
yeah I think so when I a big moment for
me and for a lot of people who are
physicists who work in his field was
when you realize that like what quantum
mechanics is I mean like you took that
first quantum mechanics course and it
like kind of blew your mind a little bit
it it says all of these things it says
that a lot of things you took for
granted we're not right or at least when
you like really look into things they
the model you have how reality works is
limited you know things don't have
positions it can be an altar place at
the same time they're waves and
particles you negative probabilities are
really useful for math for understanding
things like all sorts of crazy stuff
well not crazy but unintuitive things
and first of all I think it's a like a
very human experience to like face your
model of reality coming back at you as
like totally wrong and 210 degrees at
position which is the kind of precision
you get out of quantum mechanics like
we've tested quantum mechanics to more
precision than the relativity like we
really this theory is very accurate and
that was a really powerful experience in
my life not just cuz it made me want to
study quantum mechanics but it also made
me like a little bit more agnostic about
believing that I understand what reality
is and like how it works because if the
difference to go a hundred years back at
200 years back nobody would have thought
that this was possible right baby like
things obviously have positions and
that's what something is where it is yes
yes and that's wrong so if I phase
forward like 200 years from now
what else do I believe is like
definitely the way things behave that's
completely wrong correct and I'm sure
there's some stuff yeah and I I think
this I think more people maybe should
have that experience I'm like I'm kind
of anti too much dogma I like some
things I like how I like how Pro
humility and
we know nothing that you are because
that open that keeps us open mind and to
understand that our current
interpretations of reality may be flawed
and so it's not maybe like I think we
like I'm gonna say that's basically the
only thing I know is that is it we
perceive as flawed well at least like
what I believe is is the case is
probably not exactly totally yeah but it
doesn't mean anything's meaningless this
is different totally different yeah but
I think I like that people don't usually
believe like if I could just tell people
this stuff but quantum mechanics so like
they read like the DAO physics oh they
read some physics book and and and it
kind of just has some analogies it
doesn't actually have that kind of
impact and I think if you build
technology if you build these truths
about reality into technology that
people use okay today it's experts but
like in 50 years like maybe it's kids
playing quantum games yes and they build
up an intuition for reality based on
playing games for that intuition yeah I
think that would that would kind of
change how we think about physics would
change everything about reality and I
think one way to put a bit of a finer
point on it one of the big insights
about quantum mechanics is that physics
is different than we thought to have a
theory of physics is different than we
thought because quantum mechanics isn't
just a theory of physics it's also a
theory of information right and that's
why you have a different public you
actually have to generalize probability
theory to talk about quantum mechanics
in a better way and so it really changes
the relationship between physics and
information which is kind of a mind-body
duality shift that's been that's
starting to happen
and so I I will see them like I've
placed my bet that whatever comes after
quantum mechanics is also going to be a
theory of information as well as a new
theory of physics yeah and as this court
that's going on in
people much smarter so okay let's let's
rap on kind of the importance of the
geopolitical essence of what's going on
as well this seems to be you know a very
one of the biggest aspects of
exponential technology that is impacting
our world and how do we play fairly and
nicely with other countries around the
world as this gets developed yeah it's a
big question it's not and I don't think
it's it's an evolving situation so the
US has invested a lot in quantum
technology some of the best universities
are here but in Europe as well there's
been a lot of investment at Australia
and Japan and China and last fall I
think China announced a ten billion
dollar investment in a new quantum
computing Center which Dwarfs sitting
the US has been spending a hundred
billion yeah how do you say brother can
you spare a dime Chinese I don't shake
me for change the quantum computer
doesn't work yet it's all in that man
but that that in itself is a funny
exchange just because you can tell where
resources are being allocated by one of
the worlds you know waking Giants and
where our resources are being dedicated
so but it's not I mean there was a new
there was a new bill on the hill
recently that was passed and its first
called the National qualms initiative
bill it was passed last week Wow and it
would provide some allocation of funding
to start some programs here and you know
has to go into the Senate so like I did
I am NOT a political expert but it would
be one that one of the things that I'm
really excited about with quantum
computing is is seeing it develop in the
private sector and for private use in an
open way I think this is a way to make
the technology most useful as soon as
possible yeah
and and that's why one of the reasons
I'm very excited about about Righetti
and that a lot of us are excited about
bringing this technology into the hands
of private businesses who can we figure
out how to use it for all sorts of all
sorts of stuff so opening this
technology up for more children and
youth and just open sourcing and making
it easier for people that want to lease
time on quantum computers just literally
plug these totems into their existing
computing systems that this is sort of
the future hopefully that we can open
source and make it easier for people to
to get used to this yeah yeah industry I
mean our hope is that eventually you
have kind of a quantum AWS where you
have then all my things you can do on
cloud computers but you can accelerate
it in the same way that a GPU is an
accelerator for graphics on your desktop
you're gonna give a quantum processor a
quantum computing system as an
accelerated for a data center or a
supercomputer yep and so if we can get
there then we can we hope they still
start to solve some problems that we
thought weren't solvable before yeah
okay
just on the way out we like to ask some
questions we get to switch roles now
we'd like to ask a couple questions that
are themed with our show the first
question is do you think we're alone in
the cosmos no I don't think so
how much do want me to dive into it I've
been reading a three-body problem right
okay but in December has it that recent
paper about the the Fermi paradox right
and I'm one of the fun things that I
like to wonder about is what would like
radically different intelligences look
like yeah and so to like good flow on to
this question of like what if we built
the brain that was quantum mechanical
like well what is an intelligence at and
like an astronomical scale look like
well if you had a something that was
communicating and thought at where there
were like light-years apart could I mean
maybe you couldn't build a system
because of the speed of light that could
have intelligent thought then but maybe
could and what kind of intelligence
could could be lurking underneath
quantum physics right so we you know
there's these I don't want to dive into
it but if you seen an ant-man there's
like Wanda quantum realm right we seen
mm I don't think so you gotta go see it
they're like science it's some friends
into a quantum physicist who it's all to
a little bit on it when a man gets
really small he goes into the quantum
realm oh okay it's still like a science
fiction a hokey but there's these
fundamental beliefs about certain length
scales and yeah so it easily yeah like
the Planck length so one of the things
that quantum mechanics and and it's fall
to follow-on things tell us is that
there's no such thing as an empty vacuum
so if you have empty space then there's
actually particles popping in and out of
existence whoa in this kind of something
called like a foam or something like
that no such as a vacuum and so what's
inside there like what's going on like
what's happened so I think there's just
there's like all of these huge
differences in scale yeah and all of
like I would be surprised if only there
was evolutionary potential for
intelligent life at our scale totally I
don't examine as an intelligence could
evolve that smaller scales larger scales
different senses all these different
variables that are calculated because
information processing happens at all
those levels yeah and so if you think
about intelligence at least is some kind
of information processing and I would be
surprised if it was just had the
evolutionary pressure here okay we'll do
you think that this is a simulation it's
a space reality and I'm not going to
visit I I don't like it I don't like
this question because I do I do I love
it I don't like this question because
I'm think it's that well like well typed
right so like a simulation which is so
good that you can't distinguish it from
reality is no longer a simulation it is
reality there's no D like is no
difference between these two terms
mm-hmm so I don't think it's a well okay
so it's so if you're in a simulation
that's so good that it's
indistinguishable from a reality then it
becomes a reality
yeah how could it you just said it was
indistinguishable yeah but but then it
still exists as a simulation of a base
that is somewhere yeah so what's how
would you rephrase the question then
that there's like some vase somewhere
else yeah a base reality or a simulation
but there's no difference you said
they're indistinguishable but of the so
the base reality is the one that
simulates the simulations simulations
when you're in them you like it's a base
reality but it's really not because the
base reality is the base reality and the
simulation is just a simulation but the
question is about the advancement of
incremental advancement of technology no
matter at what rate we advanced it
eventually we in discuss live in virtual
realities that are indistinguishable you
could be living in one right now and
you're in the air mark yeah
yeah I think I think the terms are not
well defined yeah like I'm gonna if I
think if we we could have a longer
conversation on it but I think if we
really dove into the terms which would
you be worth doing yeah cuz then you
because you guys do struggle with it
you've gotta like make the questions
better cuz if you're saying like yeah
you have to define what it means to be
running a simulation and I think yeah I
think it's kind of our we have this
human tendency to use the technologies
of your day as analogies for things so
when in the Industrial Revolution people
use analogies for steam engines for how
your mind worked for your brain so we
sell these phrases around like blowing
off steam
right what it's like easy like yeah
right that skates comes it's a metaphor
from the Industrial Revolution and
because they thought that the brain
works like a steam engine or the maybe
meeting in analogy yeah exactly yeah and
so now we have neural networks and so we
do the same thing and and we're gonna
keep doing I'm sure that people are
gonna say it's like a quantum computer
when we have quantum computers yeah it
doesn't mean it is a simulation and so
now we talk about things as a simulation
because we have these simulation
technologies but I think it's just a
metaphor that we use to try and grasp it
rather and but and so I I want to bring
that up because I think some folks take
it to like a some kind of like reductio
ad absurdum ontological argument about
like meaning which i think it's probably
not maybe it's just me thinking that we
know nothing
that we shouldn't actually that's a good
point that's a good point
posing the question though is it has
some sort of ontological just beauty to
it I think made something about the
essence of being why is a potential that
it is a simulation rather than a base
reality and aren't we just going to be
simulating our own realities and future
last question whether there's that you
go to
so contest this idea of transcendental
illusion right that you should believe
something even if it you can show that
it's probably inconsistent because it
has other reasons and that may be that
may be a reason to argue against a
simulation that's a whole nother
conversation yeah I look I look forward
to unpacking this more and and this was
just you know quantum computing 101
there's you know 102 and there's there's
so much more to understand about about
what's going on with this technology and
just all these other cool conversations
and we'll have last question what do you
think's the most beautiful thing in the
world that's a strong one Wow
so I think I do actually have an answer
to this it's a it's a it's a big art
project it's a very collaborative our
project and lots of really really
talented artists have worked on it for a
really long time but it remains
consistent even though so many different
people contribute to it actually anybody
can contribute to it it's totally
accessible anyone who sort of learns how
it works can can contribute and it's not
even just purely aesthetic as an art
project parts of it have been applied to
do things to help people to make
technology maybe you know I'm getting at
but it's mathematics viewed as a whole
yeah I like that like I called it an art
project I think it is right it's I mean
people it's people talk about the
internal elegance and consistency of
parts of it and it's got all these
amazing features to it that you can view
as an as an as an artistic artistic lens
and I think one of the other reasons to
think about it that way is that we've
kind of learned a little bit more about
what mathematics is over the last 150
years and it's not really a plate miss
to you anyway it's not like we're
discovering mathematics is we're
actually constructing it inventing it
there's a lot of choices there's a lot
of aesthetic choices that go into
mathematics so I think I think the
collaborative our project of math is is
probably the most beautiful thing in the
world it's the first time we've heard
that answer I was deep that was a good
one
will what a freaking pleasure this has
been yeah thank you for coming out of
the show
teaching us about quantum computing in
our future with it yeah I love after
shows like this it just further affirms
that I know nothing I love I love it
happy to help using both yes a vote
awesome there's so much to unpack in the
future of quantum computing and what it
means the Society I'm really excited to
continue being a part of helping out
with the December
nation of this technology and the
liberation of it especially into hands
of more more kids and philosophers
ethicists computer Kroger's all
mathematicians all the different pieces
that are really needed much love
everyone thank you so much for tuning in
if you guys had a good time give us a
comment below let us know your thoughts
what are you building in this industry
what are you talking about in this
industry we'd love to hear from you also
go create after you've learned from this
content going to make cool things go
make blogs will make videos go make
companies go and execute cool things
with this also thank you to Ron our
producer and director thank you so much
to will saying and Righetti thank you
everyone for tuning in and we will see
you again soon